So, here's the deal. Notice what Destiny isn't telling you. My
attorney told me to do this because I guarantee you he hasn't
told his attorney, "Hey, I've got child pornography kicking around
on my computer. What do I do about that?" There's a discovery
demand and he has to turn that over. Pixie can't hold on. Like
I said, Pixie her attorneys. No, you like child is like Chernobyl
graphite, you guys. You can't touch it. How does discovery happen?
Well, it'll happen with what Pixie and Destiny have done or other
things Destiny has done. But the child porn that doesn't need
to be in there. You can do everything else. Did Destiny send
Pixie's pictures out without permission? That's all we're really
worried about right now. So, what research? What lawyers did
Aban Preach go to before spouting off all of this? They cited
nothing and then just declare that I'm in the wrong. The video
ends in such a bizarre way.